all right now I gotta
we did not know the coaches were going
to be cox until the first day and so
when they got out there they're like
these police all around here what do
they do it and I think I guess they're
gonna stay I know most of my dealing
with police officers in the capacity of
the police is answering a call so forth
salty some of these police office is my
last seem like they're going to be nice
but then once you get to know them
they're really beautiful nice dress the
whole objective is to you know leave
that positive impression that you know
even we're not on a baseball field if
they have to see me you know on the
street a drive-by and a squad car
something like that same coach that's my
coach that makes a big difference